[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
الطاقه الشمسيه العائمه حلل ثلاثي لمشكلات
الطاقه والمياه والاراضي
وكيف يؤثر ارتفاع معدلات الفائده على
تكلفه مشاريع الطاقه الشمسيه
[موسيقى]
الطاقه الشمسيه العائمه عاده ما يطلق
عليها اسم الركيزه الثالثه لصناعه الالواح
الشمسيه
الفوتوضوئيه الى جانب كل من الالواح
الشمسيه المثبته على الارض وتلك المثبت
على اسطح المباني تقدم الالواح الشمسيه
العائمه مقارنه بالركزيتين الاخريين فائده
اضافيه الى جانب طبعا توفير الطاقه
الكهربائيه النظيفه وهي الحفاظ على
الموارد الطبيعيه من اراضي ومياه حيث ان
نشر منظومات الالوح الشمسيه العائمه فوق
الاسطح المائيه للبحيرات والخزانات
المائيه يحمي المياه من اشعه الشمس
المباشره وبالتالي يخفف من وتيره تبخر
المياه حتى 80% في الدول ذات الاشعاع
الشمسي المرتفع وفي ضوء صح الموارد
المائيه في منطقتنا وضروره الحفاظ على
الموارد القائمه قد تصبح الالواح الشمسيه
العائمه احد الحلول المتاحه امام حكومات
ومطورين المنطقه حتى يومنا هذا المغرب هي
الدوله العربيه الاولى والوحيده في
المنطقه التي قطعت شوطا معتبرا في تطوير
مشروع للالواح الشمسيه العائمه حيث تعمل
على تشييد مشروع بقدره قصوى تبلغ 360 كيلو
واط وهناك امكانيه للتوسع اكثر بوجود سبعه
عشر سدا في البلاد وفي دراسه اجرتها جمعيه
الشرق الاوسط للصناعات الطاقه الشمسيه
ميسيا على اكبر خمسه سدود في السعوديه
وجدت ان نشر الالواح الشمسيه العائمه على
تلك الخزانات قادره على توفير
28.4
مليارتر من المياه سنويا من خلال خفض
وتيره التبخر وفي نفس الوقت هذه المنظومات
قادره على تاج واحد ونصف تيرا واتساب من
الكهرباء النظيفه وفي دراسه مماثله اجريت
في العراق كشفت ان كميه المياه التي
بالامكان توفيرها من خلال نشر الالواح
الشمسيه العائمه عند السدود العراقيه قد
تصل الى
78.3 مليار لتر سنويا الى جانب انتاج
كهرباء نظيفه بواقع 3.6 تيرا واتساب ساعه
كل عام وهناك فرص كبيره لنشر الالواح
الشمسيه عند السدود في دولنا العربيه في
حين ان مصر تخسر تقريبا ما بين 20 الى 30%
من حصتها في مياه النيل من خلال تبخر تلك
الكميات في بحيره ناصر ذو المشاريع على
الالواح الشمسيه العائمه حاليا تتركز في
دول جنوب شرق اسيا والتي تمتلك حصه 70% من
اجمالي قدرات الانتاج العالميه من هكذا
مشاريع والبالغ تقريبا خمسه جيجاوات
والسبب هو ندره الاراضي وتكلفتها في تلك
الدول ومن الميزات او الميزات الاخرى
للالواح الشمسيه العائمه ان انتاجيتها
للطاقه تزيد ب 10% مقارنه بمنظومات
الالواح الاخرى بسبب الاثر التبريدي للسطح
المائي على الالواح حيث ان التقنيات
الجديده تسمح بتركيب الالواح الشمسيه
العائمه عند مسافه قريبه جدا من سطح
المياه لتستفيد الالواح من التبريد
الطبيعي الذي توفره المياه كما ان كميه
الغبار والاتربه التي تستقر على الالواح
وتخفض من انتاجها للطاقه تكون اقل فوق
الاسطح المائيه في جانب متصل يتوقع البنك
الدولي ان منظومات الالواح الشمسيه
العائمه قادره على انتاج 400 جيجا وات في
حال تم تغطيه واحد في المئه فقط من خزانات
المياه الاصطناعيه حول العالم بتلك
الالواح
صحيح ان تكلفه تشييد منظومات الالواح
الشمسيه لعائمه تزيد بمعدل 10% مقارنه
بالمنظومات همم المثبت على الارض الا ان
انتاجيه الطاقه الاعلى التي تتمتع بها
الالواح العائمه تسمح باسترداد راس المال
المستثمر في فتره زمنيه اقصى كما ان تشييد
منظومات الالواح الشمسيه العائمه يستغرق
فتره زمنيه اقصر مقارنه بتلك المثبته على
الارض تبقى سوق الالواح الشمسيه العائمه
سوقا صغيره حتى اللحظه حيث بلغ حجم
القدرات الجديده المضافه منها العام
الماضي واحد ونصف جيجا وات فقط الا ان
هناك توقعات تشير الى ان هذا الرقم قد
يتضاعف الى اكثر من ثلاثه جيجا واتساب
سنويا بحلول عام 20 26
[موسيقى]
مشاريع الطاقه الشمسيه مره مؤخرا بتحولات
وتحديات مفصليه نتيجه تضخم اسعار الموارد
الاساسيه واختناقات سلاسل الامداد لتعيش
اليوم اضافه الى كل ما ذكرناه ارتفاعا في
تكاليف التمويل نتيجه ارتفاع نسب الفائده
لمتابعه كيف انعكس ذلك على المشاريع في
منطقتنا قبلت السيد احمد ندى رئيس جمعيه
الشرق الاوسط للصناعات الطاقه الشمسيه
ميسيا وطلبت منه بدايه ان يجلس لنا ابرز
التطورات لعام 20 22 على صعيد استثمارات
ومشاريع الطاقه الشمسيه في منطقتك
لعنه نقول ان عام
2022 كان عام استعاده الثقه في القطاع
بصفه عامه على الرغم من نحن لم نرى تصفيات
مشاريع كبرى ولكن كان هناك استمراريه في
عمليه فرز المشاريع واعاده فرز المشاريع
واولايات المشاريع في المنطقه بصفه عامه
واستمرت الجهود العامه في بعض الدول مثل
المغرب تونس لاحد ما عمان في اصدار مشاريع
جديده ولكن ليست بالاحجام الكبرى التي كنا
نسمع عنها قبل ازمه الكوفيت
فعلى هذا لا استطيع ان نقول انه كان عام
همم اعاده همم الاولويات همم رئيس
تابليزيشن همم اذا كان التعبير
للانصري بصفه عامه همم في خصوصا في حدوث
تطورات كثيره على مستوى الامتدادات وسلاسل
الامتداد همم اا اعاده تقييم الامور
بالرغم من الاجواء الجيو السياسيه المطربه
استاذ احمد في مقابلاتنا مطلع العام
الماضي 20 22
توقعت انت قيام المطورين بالتفاوض
لتاخير تسليم مشاريع الطاقات الشمسيه في
المنطقه بدلا من اعاده التفاوض على
الاسعار وذلك في ضوء ما ذكرته انت قبل
قليل من اضطراب في سلاسل الامداد وارتفاع
اسعار المواد الاوليه ابان جائحه كورونا
ماذا حدث بالفعل في همم لتلك المشاريع
خلال عام 2022 بصفه عامه استطاع جميع
المطورين خصوصا الكبار منهم ان يعيده
ترتيب اوراقم بصفه تسمح باستمريكا هذه
المشاريع وشراء الاقتصاديه همم من حيث
الدول كان لها الافضل
[موسيقى]
باعاده همم اما التفاوض بصفه تجاريه باحثه
همم اا على اسعار جديده لانهم في في الاصل
اخذوا اسعار وتنافسيه جدا همم
في العالم خلال سنوات ولكن بعض الدول ايضا
همم سامحت ب- اا تمديد فتره بدايه
المشاريع
للاستفاده من هذه
التغيرات الايجابيه التي حدثت في 2022
لصالح الجميع فنقدر نقول انه كان في ميكس
يعني او كان في خليط من اعاده التفاوض على
الاسعار اعاده التفاوض على بدايه المشاريع
اعطاء همم توقيتات بدايه المشاريع او ما
يسمى الكمبيوتر ديت همم كان هناك خليط من
من ال- همم حلول همم
بالمجموع كانت ايجابيه همم لصالح الاطراف
همم في جمل
طب ماذا عن الاوت لوك ونظرتكم المستقبليه
لعام 20 23 الحالي من حيث المشاريع
والاستثمارات التي نترقبها في المنطقه
ماذا عن البايلايف البايبلاين قوي همم
وراينا خلال اخر اسابيع من عام 2022 اا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اطلقت المشاريع
الكبرى مره اخرى في برنامج الجديد همم
دقات تصل الى تعدد وقت نفس الشيء حصل في
الامارات دبي بالتحديد همم كنا نتوقع فقط
900 ميجا واتس ولكن حصل
مضاعفه لهذه
المناقصه الى 1800 همم فطبعا هذا الزخم في
المشاريع الكبرى سيعود للمنطقها
في نهايه السنه همم
فتمت يعني اعتقد كانت مفاجاه طيبه للج في
اخر السنه والهدم مؤشر قوي على استمراريه
المشاريع الكبرى مره اخرى في المنطقه نرى
نفس الشيء في المغرب همم
اعتقد المغرب دائما كانت لها يعني همم سبق
مهم في في توليد الطاقه النظيفه بشب صفه
عامه وخصوصا طاقه الرياح همم ستستمر هذه
المشاريع همم بنفس همم اعتقد الزخم تونس
همم بالرغم من بعض ال- همم تاخيرات التي
حصلت ولكن لديها همم يعني اولويات مهمه في
المشاريع القادمه طبعا نفسها ليست بنفس
حشد المشاريع المنطقه الخارج ولكن همم في
همم استمراريه يعني كونتينيوتيوتي
للمشاريع همم طبعا سنرى في مصر بعض ال-
همم المشاريع همم
ملاحقه اكثر همم الجرين هيدروجين كمان
مثلا يتكلم وهي مرتبطه اكثر لا ربما بطاقه
الرياح اكثر نعم نعم سنه تحدث اكثر همم
استاذ احمد عن الهيدروجين النظيف الاخضر
وماذا يعني بالنسبه للطاقات المتجدده في
المنطقه ولكن اريد ان اسالك تحديدا على
مساله الاستمراريه الشرطه لها عده مرات
لكن هل فعلا سيكون هناك نفس الوتيره في
الاستمراريه في ضوء ارتفاع نسبه الفائده
الامريكيه وعالميا هذا طبعا يرفع معها
كلفه تمويل مشاريع الطاقات المتجدده همم
وتحديدا الطاقه الشمسيه همم هذا همم
يرفعها اقليميا وايضا يرفع من التعرفه
عليها هل يمكن همم ان همم تدفع ارتفاع
تكلفه التمويل تدفع دول المنطقه في اعاده
النظر في مستهدفاتها من الطاقات الشمسيه
على المدى المتوسط من حيث المستهدف حجم
المستهدف او من حيث الجدول الزمني في مجمل
الامور لا العكس هنتصور انه يستمر همم
استراتيجيه الاستدامه همم في كل البلاد
المنطقه الشرق الاوسط
والمستهدف ستظل همم همم كما هي ولكن يجب
ان نرى انه مع زياده اسعار التكلفه
الفائده في مقابل ذلك يحدث تطور ايجابي
اخر وهو عوده اسعار المواد الاوليه
الى الانخفاض بل على العكس هناك ايضا ليس
فقط المواد الاوليه ولكن ايضا عمليه الشحن
يعني نحن نرى الان اسعار الشحن التي كانت
في اعلى مستوياتها في 2021 وكانت تسبب
ازمه حقيقيه همم ليس فقط في التقطعه
الطاقه الشمسيه ولكن بصفه عامه اصبحت الان
همم في همم في مستوى منخفض ونرى انخفاضات
اكثر خصوصا في الموانئ المتطوره في
المنطقه يعني احنا ناس معنا ان الكونتينر
اللي كان ب 15,000 اصبح ب3000 همم
فقد فعلى الرغم من الوضع الجيو سياسي الذي
ادى الى همم استخدام همم ادوات فيسك
البوليسيز بمعنى اخر في حجم تكافح التضخم
او ارتفاع وبادى بذلك الى ارتفاع تكلفه
همم التمويل همم في مقابل ذلك اللي وراء
همم همم امور اخرى ايجابيه همم لا اعتقد
الناس تؤدي الى همم تغيير جذري في
المستهدفات او تغيير جذري في الجداول
الزمنيه قد نرى بعض التغيرات ولكنها لن
تكون همم يعني جبريه فتكون همم
[موسيقى]
نتوقف الان مع فاصلا قصير مشاهدينا ونتابع
بعده بقيه فقرات مستقبل الطاقه اقامه معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عاملاني اساسيان يؤثران
في اسعار الالواح الشمسيه الفوتو ضوئيه
خلال العام الحالي الاول قرار الولايات
المتحده منع استيراد الالواح الصينيه
والثاني ارتفاع قدرات انتاج البولي
سيليكون عالميا ب 70% سالت رئيس جمعيه
الشرق الاوسط للصناعات الطاقه الشمسيه
احمد ندى عن توقعاته لتاثير هذين العاملين
على الاسعار
دعنا نقول ان سيحدث هيكله تكلفه بشكل
مختلف في بعض الاسواق بطريقه مختلفه يعني
قبل الكوففت كانت هيكله التكلفه
دومنت لي او يعني بصفه اساسيه ومتحكم فيها
الصين فقط
الان يحدث تغييرات في ااا استراتيجيه
الطاقه وامن الطاقه اا فاصبح سيكون هناك
هيكله تكلفه صينيه وهي كانت تكلفه اوروبيه
ولحد ما هي كانت تكلفه امريكيه
وبهذا الخليط همم من الهياكل التكلفه همم
ستصبح نفس متعدده السيناريو الاول بالنسبه
همم جزء القائم من الصين هو سيناريو
ايجابي للصناعه بصفه عامه همم المستهدف هو
العوده الى اسعار ال 20 سنه للواط وال 21
سنه ويمكن في هذه الحدود فيما يخص هياكل
التعريفه التي ستاتي من الصين في اخر
العام همم الوضع جيو سياسي في اوروبا همم
تطور الى وجود همم دعوه يعني صارمه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكثير من الدول
الاوروبيه لاعاده النظر في همم همم
استخدامه الصين كالكصنع وحيد للعالم في
هذا المجال
فسيكون هناك هيكله تكلفه اخرى ولكنها
ستكون مناسبه للوضع الحالي في اوروبا مع
اسعار الطاقه التي قفزت قفزات رهيبه
وبالتالي همم اقتصاديات تشغيل محطات
الطاقه الشمسيه
وتصنيع الالواح الشمسيه في اوروبا ستكون
محل همم
تدقيق في الفتره القادمه ولا اتصور حتى مع
ارتفاع تكلفتها ستنازل الدول الاوروبيه عن
موقفها السيادي في الحفاظ على امنها
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
او العام الماضي بالنسبه لامريكا الوضع
همم قد يكون مشابه اوروبا ولكن همم
درايفرز مختلفه همم يعني
لا علاقه بانه بالسوق الامريكي في حد ذاته
كبير جدا
يتحمل همم
تتطابق كثير من الشركات التي فقدت
اولوياتها كمصنعين في المرحله الماضيه في
الخمس علاوات الماضيه ان تعود مره اخرى
وبقوه الى السوق الامريكي همم وفي بعض
الشركات همم يعني موقفها المادي حاليا قوي
جدا في امريكا مصر همم وشاهدنا همم يعني
همم اسعار السولار في ستوك ماركت همم
تربلت من 50 دولار ل 160 دولار في الفتره
اللي فاتت بالرغم من كل الاوضاع الماليه
العالميه يعني منع دخول الصينيه على السوق
الامريكيشن
ريدك يعني مئات المليارات من الدولارات من
التحفيز فقط
همم ففي مجمل ال- ال- الامر سنرى تغييرات
مهمه في هذا الوضع وبالتالي سيكون اسعار
مختلفه في العالم والامن الاستراتيجي
للطاقه سيكون له دور كبير في تحديد
القرارات المهمه بالنسبه لكثير من الدول
في هذا المجال همم هناك زخم واضحه عالميا
على الهيدروجين الاخضر نعود لهذه النقطه
التي جئنا على ذكرها قبل قليل همم متى
تتوقع همم بان يترجم هذا الزخم الى على
الارض بالنسبه للطاقات المتجدده في
المنطقه العربيه يعني لدينا السعوديه
لدينا الامارات لدينا مصر لدينا المغرب
جميعه يتحدثون عن همم انتاج الهيدروجين
الاخضر وتصديره همم متى نرى ذلك فعليا على
الارض ينعكس على مشاريع الشمس والريح
اتصور انه ما زال هناك
تكلفه عاليه في الجزء الخاص
بالالكتروليتور لم يحدث
التحليل الكهربائي
لم يحدث يعني بريكسرو في اسعار زيت
التكنولوجيا الى الان
فالكلفه الاجماليه للهيدروجين الاخضر لا
تزال قيد
الدراسات والبحث هل هي البديل الحقيقي
والبديل المناسب ولا
سنحتاج وقت اطول حتى التحليل الكهربائي
يكون في مستوى اسعار همم تنافسيه همم
[موسيقى]
فلا نستطيع ان نحدد تاريخ ولكن نستطيع ان
نقول ان هناك استعدادات كبرى لانه لانه
البنيه التحتيه لانشاء همم
حفص او نقاط مهمه سواء كان في الامارات او
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وحتى مصر
للهيدروجين الاخضر تحتاج الى وقت همم هو
ما تحاول مصر ان شاء الله
للقناه السويس الجزء الخاص
او الطاقه الخضراء او نظيفه سواء كانت
رياح او طاقه شمسيه همم مفهوم ولكن الجزء
الاخر لا يحتاج مجهود كبير
الاخضر ويحتاج البنيه التحتيه لهذا
الموضوع مؤقتا وفيها همم امور يعني على
مستوى الاوائل انجاز هازارديستيشن يعني
لابد من دراسات هندسيه متقدمه وهذه لم
تنتهي بعد
هناك بعد اخر وهو البعد التكتيكي اوكي في
هذا الموضوع فستطيع بعض الدول عندها
سياسات الاستدامه والمستهدفات ستظل كما هي
وبالتالي الهيدروجين في الميكس مازال
موجود على المدى طويل ولكن على المدى
القصير وفي الوضع الامني للطاقه الذي نراه
في العالم حاليا هناك بعض الدول التي
تحاول ان تتصارع في وجود حل لهذا الموضوع
وبالتالي تتسارع في همم انتاج مشاريع او
توليد او التفسير البشاريع همم بحيث
يستطيع ان همم يملا الفراغ باسرع وقت ممكن
همم وهذا يعني همم انه سيكون بالتالي في
اقفال لبعض محطات الطاقه يتعمل بالغاز همم
لابد من وجود البلد او يعني فهي عمليه
بتاعه كل بلد في الوضع اللي احنا فيه ده
همم موضوع سياسي ههه وتكتيكي بحث ليست ههه
يعني يمكن نتكلم فيه بصفه يعني تفصيليه
ولكن سنرى كثير من التكتيكات همم
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه في هذا الموضوع
لانه الطاقه وامن الطاقه هو موضوع سياسي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
المستقبل الطاقه شكرا لكرم المتابعه وانا
القاكم في حلقه الاسبوع المقبل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]